hey buddy I know it has knee Tina my god
you know time flies how are you I'm fine
yeah
little stressed but I'm good away stress
good stress okay go
lot going on on I got him juggling yeah
but but it's it's good juggling I'm
happy to be busy yeah what do you mean
by juggling what are you juggling right
now well I'm working on a new album I'm
kind of way while we're on the subject
how strange is clapping like if aliens
were to look down on us and say me what
are they doing well somebody's making
noise with their mouths and then they
liked it so they decided to hit their
arms together to show appreciation
strange culture so yeah so we're gonna
go i'm just got off the row but i'm
doing a few dates right now we're kind
of trying out some new stuff we were in
windsor and now we've got a couple
nights here in niagara which what at
waterfall so this new music what's the
vibe behind it well um it's hard to say
currently we're trying out some original
stuff we're trying out some classic
songs that weren't in a long time we're
in that phase right now we're kind of
having fun experimenting where it's just
a piano and a microphone that's how
every album starts where you just sing
ten songs a day and you just see how you
feel and you say oh that is a good song
let's google that and see what we can do
with it nine times out of ten is good
for karaoke nothing else so I've been in
the process of that and then getting
ready for this big Radio City show has
been the undertaking it's um it's a
great responsibility and it's been a lot
of fun to get ready for and we're
backstage right now you're gonna be
performing it we are we are exact same I
partner yeah we're not do you have
rituals that you go through before
hitting the stage do you get nervous you
have butterflies or you just set that
confident person now words I plea oxy on
my is basically ya know I I just you
know I
I've gotten into meditation recently I
started to do a little meditating which
is nice just kind of I calm the brain I
keep it pretty simple because I will say
that like after 18 years in this
business like as a singer
you know really well that like you can't
you have the potential to be absolutely
insane like if you start a ritual that
ritual will grow the seed of that ritual
will plant into a whole tree of all
kinds of rituals that if you don't you
know touch your elbow three times and
have the right stick of gum and have
that perfect thing like you then oh it's
I started to do it like I started to
realize you know what
you don't need Dumbo's magic feather you
know what you're doing just go out there
and have fun so now now there's hardly
anything am i right er edamame yeah a
little lean protein I like that
so bujji's but how do you take care of
your voice you know other artists talked
about their voice and taking care of it
you don't have such a beautiful voice
what do you do with that I think it's
just you know it's the hard stuff that's
not glamorous that people don't see you
know it's just all the warm-ups where
you're making weird noises and not happy
with the way it sounds and a lot of
self-criticism and then doing it again
and then doing it again and then you do
it enough so that when you go out on
stage it's fun for you and effortless to
the audience but yeah there's a lot
there's a lot that you do that just
isn't it isn't rocket science it's just
there's no shortcuts you gotta warm up
right you got to practice and you got to
be careful what you put in you know when
your voice is in you right you know I
got a I love I love wine I love tequila
I love you know the odd cigar two times
a year but but if I know I've got
singing to do you just have to be good
yeah and talking about your audience I
was reading some of the comments about
your last concert and how you music you
sing incredibly well and you're so
interactive with your audience as well
and there was a priest who sang
everything Windsor here in Windsor it's
is it important for you to be able to
connect with the other one Patrick yeah
but father is people always think that's
a plant and like every now and then I'll
like reach out to the audience like test
the water and I'll just kind of say yeah
who's out there got any requests anybody
want to say if I feel it I'll say it and
then sometimes you just hear a lot of
noise when you go all right moving on
mm-hmm and then sometimes somebody will
stand up or somebody will say my friends
a singer or whatever and you know you
never know when somebody is gonna come
to the front and you're going all right
in your hand
your microphone and then like then they
you know blow the roof off the house so
so no that's that's always fun
when I started my career my show was as
serious as my singing is and as I kind
of kept going on as I started getting
really really bored of myself I realized
oh I can be like how I am with my
friends on stage - right that's the
thing I could do yeah and and so I like
to have fun with the audience I like
them to feel like they can be loose
because there's plenty of times during
my show where it's gonna be you know
yeah big you know the big song so so no
anytime you can break that ice and have
a really good time is uh it's a good
time for me mostly you say I'm just
entertaining myself
ya know I live to make my band laugh if
I can make Tareq my guitarist or Cass if
I can make any of those guys crack up
I'm happy it might get like one from the
front row that otherwise if it's
crickets out there and laughter on my
stage I'm so great and you've been on
some of the biggest stages from the
World Series to Super Bowl I know
Demi Lovato was on the world series and
I remember you tweeted about how amazing
she was rushed it what did you think of
her at the Super Bowl
I was fantastic her voice is so great
and I'm so happy that she's like telling
her story the way she wants to tell it
and she's using her talent the way she
wants to use it and she's got such a
great talent so no it's really it's
really fun when you've got you know
great artists out there that you can
really as a singer - Justine really root
for and see them doing all kinds of
wonderful things and telling her story
you're telling your story as well that's
something that's new and I did not know
that you were dealing with it anxiety
and depression when you were younger is
that something in the past no and you
talked about the fact that you do
meditation there's that creep up for you
know well it's it's I don't think you
find tools to to cope you find ways
healthy ways to deal with it there are
plenty of unhealthy ways to deal with it
but those are always just you know
sweeping out of the rug is never
actually dealing with the root issues of
why those things exist and you know you
spend enough time self evaluating and
having great friends and and you know
therapy is great and you know you you
realize that that that kid you were so
critical of you didn't understand why
you were spinning so much or why you
were going to such dark places you you
learn to kind of get rid of some of that
blame of that younger self
you know and
find the tools to get through it music
is so healing I think a lot of times the
fans kind of assume that the music is
just for them it's a is for them to to
feel at peace with but honestly it is
just as therapeutic for the singer as it
is for the listener for me at least
that's definitely been the case so you
know I think also coming out and talking
about that stuff is symptomatic of the
fact that we are also in a culture that
I believe is more comfortable talking
about that stuff there's a lot of bad
about social media but one of the good
things about social media is it lends a
voice to people to say hey you know your
story resonated with me the song
resonated with me I've also been through
that and there is a connectivity to that
there's a comfort and knowing that you
know a million strangers know what that
feels like and if you can make each
other all feel less alone in that then
that's a good thing and so I think that
makes it much easier to talk about in
break the state even for me like I
started therapy last year I finally
faced it like I do have anxiety and it's
because people are opening up sometimes
it's just good defense you know
sometimes yeah it's just good to vent
yeah are you at a happy place now then I
am yeah really happy place yeah you know
I feel you know so much of my career was
under such a pressure cooker and you
know when you're discovered at such a
young age and you work with people who
are you know very very brilliant and
also very type-a about their brilliance
you know you get swept along for the
ride and there's a lot of figuring out
to do while you're also pretending to
kind of know what's going on which
inside you know you kind of really don't
and so now it you know the wise old age
of 38 like I feel I feel both like in
control of what I do and really at peace
with and excited about what my strengths
are and what I love to do for people but
I'm also kind of wise enough how to to
feel like I can stop and smell the roses
and it won't all just go away
location you're right yeah which is nice
I love that now 20 years ago that's when
your debut album came out yeah it's been
that night now can you believe it
and I look back at some of that old
footage and I was just like man like my
hairline went down to my Ivor
I was like I was like my hair was like a
chia pet like I was enormous and that
can like you poor creature you are so
scared right now you were so
self-loathing and and so yeah I know
it's oh what a wonderful strange trip
it's been
but but I wouldn't I wouldn't give the
the growth and the changes and the
experiments and the the journey fer for
anything in the world I think that you
know it's always easy to just stay in
one place but but that's there's no fun
in that you want to you want to keep it
fresh for yourself fresh for your
audience and keep trying new things so
that's one thing about doing concerts
now with eight albums in is I've got
eight albums worth of stories I can tell
you know from one night to another like
the show we're gonna do tonight it's
gonna be very different than yeah yeah
so you know so it's it's it's nice to be
able to kind of decide which which Josh
I would it be you know because we are
we're all multitudes yeah and you're
turning 39 39 February 27 that's this
month yeah
holy crap it's coming on 13 is okay for
he's gonna be the what's wrong with 40
or 41 I'm just saying
did so you're over that you're over it
you also have the benefit of looking
26:48 at 29 you know then you start to
varied a little more did you like
celebrating your birthday no no
absolutely not because I'm like sad
about the birthday right I'm just I'm
I just don't I just don't like I need to
work harder at like at being okay like
celebrating I love celebrate I go out
great gift giver I'll party till the
break of dawn with somebody else was
there anything I just I just can't I
just don't I'm gonna call you on your
birthday and sing happy birthday very
sweet can I do that for you yes there
were 27 I'll call you 9:00 a.m. in the
morning all the kids get up at 5:00 so
I'll tell you what 5:00 in the morning
yes thank you coastal Evian will I be in
Japan let's see
work out yeah sure that'll be very very
sweet what do you want to do next
um I what would I like to do next that's
a good question
I mean I kind of feel like the Ducks
that I have lined up or things that I'm
really excited about I'm really excited
at this Radio City show it gives me a
chance to kind of break out even further
into aspects of my live show that I
haven't really been able to explore as
deeply as I would have one that wanted
in the past you know you're in the
confines of a concert so you can't do
certain things and so what Radio City
Music Hall has given me with this night
every couple months is a really long
runway to craft a night unlike anything
else I've ever done in my career each
time it's gonna be totally different so
that's a big that's a big fun thing that
I'm about to do I'd love to go back to
Broadway yeah I miss that community
I miss the camaraderie of it and it was
my first dream and I love to a comedy no
more acting I'd love to do more cop yeah
yeah look love to do more more acting
serious or comedy I'd love I love to in
comedy and the music side is so serious
I'm I feel like comedy is a is a rhythm
that I really like to like to play with
and so it's um yeah so so there's a lot
of things a lot of things in the work so
I can't wait to tell you all about when
the time comes
have you reached your definition of
success um I don't
I will admit I mean in so many ways yes
like on paper sure but for yourself do
you have you achieved what you wanted at
you I still need to get better at like
balance in my life like because yeah
career-wise absolutely like I am like a
little behind all the other stuff you
know so you know one of these days I
would love to start a family and I'd
love to you know at some point like be
the dad to my kids my dad and us you
know but it's it's hard because when you
make a decision to dive into this kind
of universe you know it's yeah there's a
lot of pressure and there's a lot of
places you have to go and you have to
pick up the phone you got to go to
Sweden you got to go somewhere else so
you know there's been a lot of things
have gotten in the way of making me feel
like it would be fair to a family right
now and so making time to do that would
be a would be a going to be perfect when
you turn 39
there you go 39 that's what you're gonna
be doing every day that's it
becoming a dad
[Laughter]